let's get to it man look blue light cat
podcast
uh one of my favorite rappers uh one of
my favorite people in in
in the business man action bronson bam
bam
yeah good to see you again my brother
how you gonna see
you too man i'm good bro i'm good yo
it's only right
you know the first time i've ever taken
a dab was with you man
that's right and i remember you went la
la land yes
it was backstage uh mac miller
uh chance tour celebrity theater
yeah you took advantage of me though
because you uh you had me take three
back to back to back like it wasn't
like it wasn't a big deal and then i was
[ __ ]
for like like five hours after that
we had to make sure you had a good night
oh yeah that was crazy
i think that's the highest i've ever
been outside of eating too many edibles
have you ever had a really bad edible
experience action
uh you know what you just kind of have
to go with it you just have to go with
the flow go with the wave
a good friend of mine who's sitting over
here and on the couch has had some
pretty interesting uh
um edible situations know
it can get deep so you pretty much sit
you sink into wherever you're at
sink into the abyss you know it's like
it's like you drown in your own fluids
what about any have you ever had any
wild hallucinogenic experiences whether
it's mushrooms or
any like dmt or anything crazy yeah
plenty not always is always a crazy
situation what's the craziest trip
there's been so many crazy ones but
it's like the the latest the latest one
the latest one is always the craziest
one is because you remember it the most
these things are almost like flashes in
time where you remember bits and pieces
but you cannot really explain it
right you know what i'm saying but there
are there are points where i can explain
what i'm trying to say
but not this one because i'm looking at
that barkley poster in the back
oh you see that charles barkley poster i
got here look i got the
i got this i have that in my room yo man
y'all from phoenix so we got a rep
and then i got the old jacket in my room
right there the bang 316 with vince on
there
that's fire yeah that's crazy you had
the barkley poster were you a barkley
guy coming up like growing up i was a
big
i mean i love barkley it was my favorite
shoe
oh those shoes were incredible yeah he
was a sick dude he was like he was
definitely one of my favorite players
growing up there's no doubt
he was no threat to the knicks well yeah
i guess when he played on the sixers
otherwise he was in the western
conference and that's what i mean
yeah yeah it's almost like you can
acknowledge somebody who's on the other
side of of the conferences and be like
you know what i [ __ ] with that guy
because
i don't have to worry about him in the
eastern conference finals
it was never a situation yo that's fair
back to your uh mushroom trips has have
you ever
i've i just started to do mushrooms i
did mushrooms for the first time in
february
and it was like kind of therapeutic
low-key was that something that like
do you do you find like therapeutic um
like do you find it to be therapeutic
whenever you do that [ __ ]
you have to eat more just keep eating
more
well how many did you eat did you eat a
little bit or a lot
i had a lot man i had like a half of a
chocolate bar
yeah i don't know what that i i don't
know what goes into the chocolate bar so
what
what i'm what i suggest is you grab a
handful of mushrooms and stuff them in
your face
and then if you could actually talk to
me in an hour
eat some more i would like to hear about
it after you come home
so just go all just go all the way in
well
what's the fun and not you know you're
gonna [ __ ] have a little piece of
chocolate bar who even knows what you're
doing you might have just taken [ __ ]
you know who knows they might have put
shiitake mushrooms in there and you're
[ __ ]
eating shitakes and you're feeling funny
what would be the advice you'd give to
anyone as far as like your surroundings
or
where you need to be at mentally before
you take take the all those shrooms to
the face because this is a lot about who
you're around and where you're at
so many factors there's so many
it's very situational
yeah it's like you have to be [ __ ]
bill belichick to get it right
but for real at the end of the day you
have to you know you you'd like to be in
nature
but there's been times where i've had
some sicko trips inside you know
that's what's up we lost you know
there's been times where hours have been
lost
days have been lost you wake up you have
no idea what's going on
every time is different what i suggest
is you just try it all
just try it try it all see what works
for you
is there a drug that you've tried that
you would not suggest anyone try
yeah don't smoke dust don't do angel
dust
i don't know would you is that
considered angel dustin i'm talking
about when you dip a cigarette or you
dip a blunt into that [ __ ] liquid
formaldehyde
yeah the [ __ ] man used to rap about dust
dip yeah philly rappers like that [ __ ]
philly people
that's a big it was a big deal over
there it's big in like staten island and
the bronx
stay away from the town yeah no it's
dust is no good
that was a bad experience for you yeah i
remember i hit the dust and i got the
flu for 14 days
[ __ ] yeah that's crazy
it was like [ __ ] 15 years ago but yo
that's crazy yeah it was bad
hey man um your new album uh is called
only for dolphins
sure is which is a remarkable name for a
project
thank you very much um i
i really think that uh latin grammys is
crazy i love the video
because i know you've always the strong
man competition guy you've all
you've been talking about how you came
up watching those throughout the years
and
um only for dolphins why is it named
only for the dog for for dolphins and um
it makes me want to eat mushrooms while
listening to it because i feel like
that's what you should be doing i feel
like that's how you listen to an album
named only for dolphins
100 percent on white bronco i
said on the song called mount etna yup
[ __ ] don't deserve me you know
what i mean
my next album is only for dolphins
because [ __ ] don't deserve me
and that's you know that's i've kind of
run with that theme
okay this album is for the this album is
for the
guardians of the ocean that's that's
fair
um straight up i've made enough for
[ __ ] man it's time to
to give to give to the ones who really
want to receive
100 um you are it's crazy how long
you've been doing this and how
you're still in some some way i don't
know man i feel like
somehow you're still kind of underrated
when it comes to like the conversations
like these hip-hop conversations like um
do you feel like
is that kind of why you said that on the
last album like [ __ ] don't
deserve me because i feel like you don't
you you as much as you're like known for
your vice [ __ ] and your cooking [ __ ] and
all everything else like you're still
like
one of the the hardest dudes on the mic
and i feel like sometimes people
thank you man people kind of overlook
you in that in that respect
now you know
i i can only do what i do you know
the show did take over in a crazy way
where people definitely know me a lot
from that and
you know you you want to be able to you
know bring everything together to a head
but
like i said i [ __ ] i've ushered in
this in the 2010s
you know i've ushered that [ __ ] and i'm
here 2020
still headlining [ __ ] i'm you know
[ __ ] this is
this is like i'm trying to do emmett
smith career you know
rap is like running back it's very
short-lived career you get hurt
bum knee get cut you don't have the same
performance as last year you have one
big performance then the next year
you're down
down on you they cut you someone picks
you up off waivers
that's what this rap [ __ ] is you're a
[ __ ] running back
i'm looking for the longevity you know
or when however long that i'm i'm
battling out my way
we're we will we will take you in
arizona if you would like to retire in
arizona
that's what i'm saying i'll [ __ ] you
know emma smith my career ends in
arizona with the record
with the record with all-time record yup
after a big
53-yard performance that day it was only
53 yards
i don't it seemed like you're right 25
carries 53 yards
that's crazy to think i remember that
but he was a workhorse
yes that's what i am i'm a workhorse but
you know like you said man you know
it you're you you transcend
yourself through in rap it's been almost
you can consider it like light years at
this point but a decade
[ __ ] changes so rapidly and so quickly
to still
you know have a shot my fan base is
solidified and
i you know i always continue to you know
i'll be new to
somebody today you know someone just
find out about me today
yeah it's crazy to think i saw you said
that uh i was out there on twitter
instagram that your first album was 10
years ago
it really was it was you know 10 years
ago was the first project dr lecter came
out and
dr lecter and then well done right with
static yeah
yep yeah it's it's so crazy because it
makes me just feel old as [ __ ] because i
i still remember discovering i forget
which record it was when you were
rapping on the basketball court with the
next jersey on you just
experienced you're experienced yeah um
you know it's it's dope though to see
kind of the pivot that hip hop has taken
since you started
i do feel like what you and
and static and obviously you know you an
alchemist and i feel like
the the the wave of of being um
high tier with your bars is kind of
coming back yeah and i feel like you
kind of helped
bring that back and it's you know with
guys like razelda
and you know one of your peers like
freddie gibbs who's had a great you know
last 12 months like do you feel like
rock martial rock marxiano
you know like we're talking about 2010
talk about mossberg you know like
we were me and mayhem bumping that [ __ ]
nonstop you know we love rock
rock is definitely one of those you know
leaders when it comes to straight bars
and
fire ass beats you know another person
who doesn't get enough love
but it's blasphemy because you know the
people who really
who are in the know it's connoisseur rap
you know it's like
you're either smoking something you're
smoking some whatever or you're smoking
what i smoke you know what i'm saying
yeah and there's not many people that
are smoking what i'm smoking so i
feel what i understand that i i get the
game
this is for [ __ ] certain people you
know
only for dolphins who do you have a
production on there man
myself aka i'm calling myself the greek
anytime i hear a sample of something
that i like and i have one of the homies
flip it
like al right mugs derringer
it's called produced by the greek so
you'll know that
go you want those beats go to the greek
you straight up
you gotta go see the greek the funny
thing is they know me as the greek but
i'm not even greek
right you're albeit no that [ __ ] is
great by the way shout out to the greek
in the wire i just i just rewatched the
wire during uh
this whole thing i i haven't seen it in
you know maybe eight years
and season two man is so much better
than i remember
it's like a slap don't understand why
that's the most slept on season because
there's not as much [ __ ]
you know i don't know like drug dealing
or something is it
the wire takes you on different angles
you know takes you into
from the [ __ ] the newsroom the school
you know the [ __ ] yeah yeah the pier the
docks you know the long shoremen down
there it's not a [ __ ] game what do
you think all the crazy [ __ ] comes it
comes from the ports
no season two was uh i like re-watching
it i i have it either second or third
place in my favorite wire seasons and
when i first watched it i remember just
being so thrown off
because if you watch vodka sobaka rest
in peace they did him dirty man
and you see like [ __ ] like that is is
it's inspiring so the end of that season
a song called
fpj fej is playing dun
dun dun dun dun so i rhymed on that back
then
so it was like i've i've always been
inspired by crazy beats
saying ridiculous things as i can over
these beats
you know i just do what i [ __ ] do man
i do what i
do the best i can and that's all i can
say about that
that's fair um i i was just with uh
gashy who's a fellow albanian uh yes sir
and he was extremely uh well first of
all he played me
the unreleased verse that you did for
him
he's the best he's funny and i was like
bro why did this yeah big albanians
i was like why did this not make that
out for by the way the the verse was
something crazy
it was like it was like vintage action
it was some quickie
it was like work yeah but it was dope
but i i think it
you know he caught me on the spot man i
told him come over here hang
out in like a true albanian you put me
on the spot yeah
but we're talking about you know like a
true albanian i deliver
true um but we're kind of talking he was
he was kind of really really like
talking about when he goes home like the
fact that like
certain maps you can't find kosovo on
certain like apple maps and there's like
the you know yeah i did see that i
remember being there and it wasn't on
the map and
and just the the the idea of like you
know there's the two flag situation
i i just watched the episode i just i
dived into a youtube wormhole of
[ __ ] that's delicious like last month
and i saw the episode where you went
back home to your grandma's house
um and you know you're obviously walking
around you're a freaking celebrity out
there you're like you're like
jay-z in albania um i mean you know
there's
there's very you know it's a very small
amount of it's like a you know
it's like a small amount of people and
when you become famous in america
it's like [ __ ] you're michael jackson
no matter what
he was talking like uh that you're
you're one of the only other artists
um that really represent where you're
from like that
and that there's other artists that are
from that area
that i didn't even know about and he was
like see that's the problem you don't
know that but you know that me and
action are from there because we
we represent that [ __ ] you know like
what representing where you're from yeah
just like he was saying there's a bunch
of other art he listed a bunch of other
artists that were
albeit mentioned anybody you mentioned
dua lipa and um
i know but do it 100 percent always reps
where she's from hey you
know where she's from she's just a pop
star you know what i'm saying so people
misconstrue maybe you know
right but do is one million percent
you know hundreds i asked she's the one
who brought me out there
i saw you did the festival with her out
there yeah she's the one who brought me
home
right right right her and her father
they brought me home
you know like they brought goshi there
you know
what about brothers home over there the
belushi's how big of a deal were the
belushi's growing up as a kid
i mean we didn't know the belushi's were
albanian that's the thing
and then you know you catch wind of it
like one of oh they albania is that
but now you know jim always comments on
my on my pictures and [ __ ] and we have
like little talks on dm
he's he's always in the pot and [ __ ]
like that
it's just pretty amazing he's a [ __ ]
you know he's just a normal dude
and you know it seems like all albanians
show each other love for the most part
but i don't i don't think that there's i
think that albanians like are
some of the hardest repping human beings
that there are when
someone's obeying you they'll [ __ ]
let you know immediately
you don't even have to it's worn on them
in a way you know a hundred percent it's
one on them and i'm proud of i'm proud
of that because that's where
my roots are that's i grew up with my
albanian grandparents in my house
i grew up that way i was brought up in
that manner i go home over there just
feels
it feels normal feels everything
everything is is okay you know
and your grandma had came out to the
states to kind of like help raise you
right
they didn't come to space for that that
who knows what the hell they came in for
we they there was
war it was communism over there was when
yugoslavia was breaking up
okay when it broke up into a lot of
different places you know
oh it's always been we come from
war-torn war-torn land
100 possible i remember seeing that [ __ ]
on the news as a kid man
like the clinton macadonski yeah it's a
lot of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
um back to um only for dolphins you said
you the greek has got production on
there yourself
um derringer who scavenger fraud
uh al the lineup mugs hey listen these
are the people that have been with me
from the beginning that i've known that
i talked to on
you know all the time you and derringer
how did that because obviously
derringer's having a hell of a run right
now with the whole griselda crew and i
do feel like
his sound is tailor-made for you as well
um where did you guys initially first
link up at and like how did you become a
fan of what he's doing
man i didn't i just met derringer as
as a person you know like maybe three
four years ago when i
when we were meeting everybody um i had
already met gunn
and conway i believe but and then
derringer came back to new york or some
[ __ ] like that and i just met him he was
the producer he was cool as [ __ ]
we started working chilling he came out
for a little bit
he's just like he's one of the guys you
know he just he's [ __ ] funny as hell
he's a good dude
and he makes amazing music and he he's
like
he knows music you know it's not just
like he's sitting there making
you know hitting a drum machine you know
it's like it's different it's hard
you know and uh like i appreciate him
and the stuff that he does for griselda
and the fact of the matter is that he
does
completely different things for me which
is you know
shows his his versatility and i feel
like that's something
with him that kind of gets lost he
thinks he thinks of him for one thing
but
if you look if you listen to the songs
that he's produced for me
they're different they're totally
different songs and it's giving you a
totally different side of him so
it shows his versatility in in being
able to
make great stuff um
how as being one of alchemist's closest
friends
and you know a lot of people associate
you two together how dope has it been
just to kind of sit back and just see
the year he's having man because he's
having
a year seems like every year again he
has another year i mean he just doesn't
he just
[ __ ] this is his destiny this is what
he was born to do
you know 2020 has been uh epic man he's
born to make fire he's just he just has
it you know he's just [ __ ]
he's just good would you guys do another
joint project together
[ __ ] make [ __ ] a million joint
projects with him
[ __ ] 20 million songs i do [ __ ] do
a whole
discography i would do anything that's
what's up um
who else is on only any any um mc
features on only for dolphins
just mayhem loren and his brother
hologram
which is my two closest friends you know
shout out to mayhem mayhem has also been
doing his [ __ ] thing man
forever man shout out to mayhem shout
out to hologram hugging
our consensus favorite rapper since he's
been rapping
everybody in the crew how long's
hollywood best
i mean since you know for a while now
but you know he's brand new
he's right he's fresh out he's fresh
he's fresh he's fresh as a [ __ ]
yo what has been the uh obviously with
kovid going on in this pandemic you've
you've kind of taken the advantage of
like a lot of people man
i know when the first month of of this
[ __ ] i was just eating and sitting
at home getting fatter and yeah i
started to get my [ __ ] together and i
it's been dope to see you take advantage
of this time to like get get right i
know you you know you you um you have
your new baby and
i saw that that was like a big
inspiration for why you wanted to get
your health right
but um like like is there anything that
you would give like most people i think
dieting is the hardest part right
i mean you know when if you talk about a
diet like doing [ __ ] atkins or keto
that's hard because you have to stay on
some regimented [ __ ] and you're gonna
you're bound to fall off right it's
about changing the actual lifestyle
and it's crazy that i'm even able to
talk about this because like
six months ago i could tell you about it
but i wasn't living it
you know i was [ __ ] eating cakes and
cookies and [ __ ] pounding sugar and
[ __ ] compounding it with
meats and [ __ ] nasty just eating like
a [ __ ] animal like what the hell am i
doing i'm not [ __ ]
thinking about college i'm not in
[ __ ]
rutgers you know having a bowl of
[ __ ] apples having an apple jacks
bowl at [ __ ] three in the morning i
haven't had [ __ ] cereal in six months
because i eat two boxes of it
and it's not even sugary cereal it's
some like old man cereal you know
and i just like it so it's a lifestyle
change
you have to change yeah you have to
change your eating habits and you have
to change your laziness
you have to change your mindset about
starting tomorrow and doing this you
[ __ ] start immediately you got to
just do it
you got to get out there and you got to
force yourself to move
the only way to [ __ ] make yourself
better is to do things you really don't
like to do
and force yourself to do and you're
going to learn it's going to become
something that's embedded in you
and that's what i do that like when i go
to the gym i do the
[ __ ] that sucks i do the hardest [ __ ] i
ask for the hardest circuits the longest
the [ __ ]
most strenuous the [ __ ] that makes me
want to [ __ ] barf that i'm
drenched in sweat but when i'm done with
that
and i've achieved there's no highlight
that you know
is it uh what's the one thing you miss
eating the most
since you've started i really just i
crave
pasta and i crave pizza i don't really
like nothing i'm not even like
once you're off the suites for like two
weeks you're done
you get that out of your system i think
a month or whatever whatever it is
you're just done with it you don't need
that [ __ ] no more
i just need [ __ ] pasta in every kind
of way
filled with cheese filled this one baked
i feel like you could have pizza once in
a while without the cheese you know
even with the cheese i like you know you
can have it once in a while
so you can do you cut down although i
would do every day did you cut dairy out
of your diet
fully 90
i do shave some parmigiano reggiano on
things
but it's more of like a hard aged
cheese which really doesn't count it's
like eating [ __ ]
natural yeast natural yeast
i like to [ __ ] think of it in that
way nutritional yeast
oh that's great have you been
like what's with sports this year has
been so [ __ ] weird me and your big
sports guys i know you're a big baseball
guy
um have you what have you been thinking
so far of the way that
have you even been watching any baseball
this year or any sports at all because
it's been kind of it's been kind of
weird you'll wake up at like 11 a.m and
there'll be like a basketball game on
and and sunday there was basketball
football and baseball on which was
amazing because that's never happened
before yeah
i'm not investing my time in football
anymore because my team doesn't isn't
worth it
so that are you a jets or giants guy
what do you think i'm a jedi
giants are worth they're still kind of
worthy you know they're trying right the
jets the jets are gonna they
it kind of just not worth it in general
so i don't waste time on sundays i
haven't really been watching tv
i listen to games a lot on the on the
radio so i like to listen to susan and
john
talk about the yankees you know so
that gets me happy and then i'm watching
ufc only
i'm watching bella i'm watching fights
whatever kickboxing whatever bellator
whatever ufc is on i'm watching it
non-stop that's all i care about ufc has
done a great job of uh
and it's you know for the past i don't
know from years now it's been the best
sport to follow for me
yeah that's fair it really it gives it's
a gift that keeps giving
yeah i think it's uh also like the
like the the most like i think when you
watch any any sport for the most part
like you know there's load management in
the nba
there's just like some [ __ ] that you can
complain about when you watch ufc it's
like nah it's two [ __ ] in the
middle of a ring
and that's all your body calls you out
if you [ __ ] duck somebody you're
getting called out if this happens
no matter it's like [ __ ] real [ __ ] no
matter what you have to see somebody you
have to [ __ ] go through them you have
to fight and that's going to be that
if not you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
everyone knows it
um what is the best part of of the
quarantine
i know that there's a lot of down parts
but what is the part that you feel like
you've appreciated the most about the
world kind of chilling for a little bit
you know it's unfortunate for all the
people who
uh lost their jobs and yeah of course
my grandma passes lost their homes you
know lost their lives lost everything
and you know i i hate to turn you know i
i hate to like
i'm not really boasting about it but
i've definitely you know i go on with
the mind frame of positivity always so
i did kind of change my whole [ __ ]
around so it forced me to just chill
i have a brand new baby so i was able to
be with my child every single day
you know watch him grow every single day
get his first little teeth take his
first little step
make his first little noise you know
what i mean so
feed him nourish him take care of my
lady
spend time with her do nature situations
and really you know recharge and get a
grasp on ourselves and
and reflect kind of i mean you know it
was a forced reflection and i i need i
i definitely needed this because if i
didn't who knows what would have
happened maybe i would have died or
been in a [ __ ] hospital or some [ __ ]
who knows what the [ __ ]
yeah i think it was like a forced like
it kind of re forced everybody to get
their priorities together
yeah you know what i'm saying well not
everybody you [ __ ] a lot of people's
minds up and they went the other way but
you know
only the strong survive and you know
hopefully hopefully people will be able
to you know to overcome
yo look man quick break from the podcast
and tell you about odd socks
all right they're our official sponsor
they support what we do here at the
bootleg kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
outsocksofficial.com
if you wanna support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks for sure uh the
album comes out friday right
well [ __ ] tomorrow night i don't even
know what the [ __ ] was today today's
wednesday yeah i don't even know 25
25th so next week next week next friday
only for dolphins what is the for
dolphins
what is the um the latest which with you
and uh
vice and and and the show because i i
remember that there was like a little
falling out
and then i thought i saw you back on or
is that done
there's always a fall now when there's
situations that are you know when people
are dishonest and there's things that
aren't without an
upheld but we overcame one of the
situations and we ended up putting out
season four
and that's the end of the contract did
four seasons five seasons
no couple on instagram on youtube and
now i'm i'm continuing that
100 myself on i'll be putting it up on
my youtube channel on action crossing
youtube
dad that's what i was going to tell you
like you should just do that [ __ ] on
your own bro
i i mean it's my show i invented it i
named my [ __ ]
they don't own it i own it it's my hand
and i'm assuming
we're still going to have mayhem and
bess and and the crew
uh well it's not really feasible at this
point and i think everybody's going to
be doing their own shows right now
everyone's gearing up to do their own
little thing so i'm
i'm just sticking with what i'm it's
like a vlog of my life
and my fitness and my journeys and my
food and
you know this is my life i'm saying i'm
a chef
i do these things i love food
i review food this is what i do this is
my [ __ ]
you know what i mean that's what i do so
i'm going to continue always doing that
and everybody's gearing up for their own
style of show
whatever they do it looks [ __ ]
everyone's stuff is looking really fire
what what's uh what's the look at that
we create [ __ ] four spin-offs
all four [ __ ] ideas that shit's crazy
yeah i want to see i want to see i'm
gonna spin off master all i do is create
[ __ ] ideas this let's do this let's
do this let's do this
and vice was really great at one point
for getting it done
yeah i think yeah we had some good
people in position
that would yes anything and i'm happy
about that because
it was a good idea for them and for us i
mean the idea that you had a tv show
watching ancient aliens while getting
high with your
friends is that not the best show ever
created that shit's
incredible that's going to continue also
my friend
for sure um you talked about
uh you you review food and all that [ __ ]
since you've been eating healthy what is
you food no but like obviously we love
to watch [ __ ] that's delicious but since
you started to eat healthy what has been
the one restaurant or or place that
you've discovered
or even a dish that you've discovered
that you might not have [ __ ] with
before because i know me i look down at
a lot of like i'll look at a menu and
i'll see the vegan options i'd like [ __ ]
out of you with that like i'm good
like what's something you've discovered
whether it's a restaurant or a dish that
you that
that since that choosing the healthy
lifestyle that that's really
you know impressed you i don't know if
it's
i don't know if it's discovering
anything it's always just trying to
adapt
when you go somewhere are you looking at
a menu i've made mostly
every meal on my own this you know this
whole time up until maybe a couple
months
i mean i've been trying to bake a lot
and i'm doing lots of different things
that i you know
if i ate them it would be bad but i give
it away so i bake i give [ __ ] away
just testing the waters testing things
out creating recipes and [ __ ] like that
but i like simple [ __ ]
if i'm gonna go vegan i'm gonna eat
vegetables i don't need a burger
that's made out of vegetables to look
like a burger you know i like
vegetables i actually like it right
you know so i it's
it's nothing that i've discovered it's
just discovering
eating well and still having flavor
that's really what it's about
because you think that would you know
what eating healthy is
not not flavorful you have to eat like
steamed chicken
steamed broccoli
nah you have to have good fats this it's
all balanced man it's all a [ __ ]
i'm writing a book [ __ ] that there's
gonna be a new book
i got i got two of your books upstairs
i'm writing three new books
okay what the hell this [ __ ] is another
thing all i care about is doing things
that i like doing man ain't nothing
stopping me
and now your eyebrows my mind's sick
it's over
i'm i'm just happy to see you 100
independent on all fronts
on the music on the [ __ ] content side
like well i mean i did just sign a
little deal with loma vista but it does
feel independent
but it's not exactly the album yeah for
this album no
okay yeah and that album is coming out
the 25th
sure is now when you when you
like you say you signed something with
loma vista i haven't heard of them but
what's something that you
that was important like to find somebody
because you obviously just got out of a
deal the last project was independent
through it it was through empire right i
mean that's what does that mean
yeah that means it was independent i
mean they distributed it on all the dsps
yeah yeah that's all that means
but um but what what what what made you
i don't even know what distributed on
all this why the [ __ ] can't i do that
myself like yo
oh no you can a hundred percent yeah so
i mean uh
loma this i didn't hear them either but
then they explained some of the artists
they have and they have some really
great artists like
saint vincent like like big like they
have denzel curry they have
uh a bunch of other people that are cool
you know
and um just everybody said that they had
a
you know a cool little situation over
there and i talked to them and i felt
good about it and i talked to the owner
of the company and he was a real good
dude
and the view was exact i wanted i wanted
some help you know i wanted a little bit
of help behind me because i'm doing all
this stuff on my own
at least on that side let's get some
push all the other stuff i can do on my
own like all the art situations all the
ancillary stuff but the actual
music situation and pushing it out just
slight
help so that's really the [ __ ]
thought process behind that
would you ever do a podcast action
because you are an amazing storyteller
um yeah i don't really like talking that
much
hey man but you could talk i mean i can
but i'm not you know how many [ __ ]
times
this is not like you know i always i
love doing interviews with people but it
gets
tiring but for you i'll always do an
interview with you
because you're my guy from the beginning
and you know it's just it gets [ __ ]
tedious bro like if you had to do these
things all the time
you feel it's like especially when
you're doing like that generic radio
running generic one it's not even like
sometimes even sometimes the ones that
you think they're not going to be
generic has just become so
tedious and [ __ ] like like so
it's [ __ ] magic mind numbing it's my
numbing so
you know i like i like more i like
thinking more than i like talking a lot
that's fair on camera you know i like
talking with friends and [ __ ] i like
conversing there
yo i don't know i don't know man one of
my favorite stories you told me was when
the
when you met michael jordan and he had
jeans that you that reminded you of
jinkos
yeah he definitely had jingles on 100
give me um what what he had the chain
that was attached to his wallet
you met michael jordan it was back it
was it was like at a jordan event and i
think you were you said
were you with fat joe no fat joe was
there i'm sure
who was i was with paul rosenberg
and you met michael jordan and you like
well then [ __ ] michael jordan i met
moses malone that night
you know what i'm saying i shook i shook
moses malone hand
i took a piss at a urinal and then
came next to me was clyde drexler
and [ __ ] uh i forgot who else
dominique wilkins you had dominique
wilkins and clyde drexler on each side
of you
paul pillering me while i'm pissing oh
my god
it was nuts that's a crazy lineup right
there yo you look to your right you see
clyde and then you see dominic who
who do you think like like that's gotta
be the
biggest piss in your life
you're never ever ever supposed to look
right or left at a urinal
you [ __ ] keep your goddamn eyes on
your own well i'm not saying you're
looking at their [ __ ] i'm saying you
like they're [ __ ] six
foot eight you know what i'm saying like
that that's how tall they are if i look
right i'm [ __ ] looking at it
you're looking at their dick i look left
glad drexler's balls are in my direct
eyesight because he's [ __ ] 6-6
you know it's just science it's not you
know
science that's got to be a hell of a
night to meet all those guys
yeah magic johnson [ __ ] that's the
night i met cece's abathia who's a long
time friend now i like him very very
much
prince fielder was a very ill dude i
like him very much
so a lot of people were there it was
like okay chris paul
incredible well look marcus aldridge all
the jordan athletes were there
action prince performed i always tell
this
prince he was prince [ __ ] performed
prince performed well listen man
um i always appreciate you action and
i'm always excited when you drop music
because i feel like
sir i think i just put some new [ __ ] out
today mongolia
i didn't want to put another song out
but we you know what the [ __ ] what are
we gonna do
it's coming out anyway it's it's coming
out anyway
there it is go get it mongolia the album
comes out next week and um
man i'm excited for it so um
make sure you tap in with the album
pre-order it and all that [ __ ] and go
watch the video
is the mongolia video is there a video
for that there'll be a mongolia video
there'll be a golden eye video
next week but go watch latin grammys
go watch latin grand [ __ ] best song
best video
it's the [ __ ] fire i don't give a
[ __ ]
remix remix with pitbull and baby bash
coming soon
remix with [ __ ] okay remix with
[ __ ]
baby bash sean paul
pitbull who else vicente fernandez
nah and [ __ ] the last
boy scout rampage the last boy scout
my guy i appreciate you tapping in bro
thank you brother i'll talk to you soon
yes sir